hello and welcome everyone to yet
another
tech enthusiastic video from simply
learn today
we will learn about servlets in java so
without much of add-o
let's quickly begin with our session now
let's have a quick look on the agenda
for today's session
first we will understand what exactly is
a servlet
clearly then we will move ahead into
java servlets lifecycle followed by that
we will understand the java servlet
architecture once we have a good
understanding of what exactly is a
servlet and its lifecycle
along with its architecture we will move
ahead into its features
after finishing with the features we
will now enter into the practical
session
where we will understand setting up the
environment for java servlets
now setting up the environment for java
servlets is the most tedious task and
many fear it
but in actual case it is not at all
difficult
i will show you how to set up the
environment for java servlets and
execute a sample program
for a better understanding of java
servers practically
after that we will discuss some of the
major advantages
and disadvantages of using java servlets
followed by that we will learn the cgi
with a brief introduction
then the differences between cgi and
servlets
next up we will learn how the requests
and response work
finally we will conclude the session by
learning the process of
session tracking and cookies hope we are
clear with the agenda
now let us quickly start the session so
the first
question what exactly is a servlet
now imagine you're searching for some
information on the internet
you open your local browser and start
typing it
this question from you to the internet
is called as request
so further this request is sent to the
cloud
or in technical terms your browser sends
your request to the respective server
responsible for storing for that
particular information
and helps you with it when requested now
the server gets triggered with your
request and in written
it helps you back with the information
you have requested for
this answer from the server is called
the response
so this is how the request and response
work in a server
for this process to happen so smoothly
and effectively
we need a servlet digging a little deep
into the server
we find the component responsible for
such an effective job
it is called the servlet container that
holds
java based web application and a set of
individual components called as servlets
now we are close to our answer so this
particular java based component takes
care of
web requests and response to sum it up
with the form of a definition
we can define it as follows a servlet
is a java program that runs on the java
enabled web server
or application server they are used to
handle the request obtained from the web
server
process the request produce the response
and then
send a response back to the web server
now hoping that it was a clear
explanation
can we move ahead with the next topic
so the next topic we have is so how does
the servlet work in reality
or more practically or in depth what's
the life cycle of a servlet
so the life cycle of a servlet in real
time has the following stages
these stages are the ones that a java
servlet actually follows in real life
to get our work done so the stages are
init service and
the crud operations which are the get
post put delete and finally
destroy now let us understand each one
of them in a bit more detail
the first one is the init process
the init method is called only once it
is called only when the servlet is
created
and not for all the requests afterwards
so
it is used for the one-time
initializations just
as with the init method of applets the
servlet is normally created when a user
first invokes a url corresponding
to the servlet but you can also specify
the servlet is loaded
when the server first started when a
user invokes a servlet a single instance
of each servlet gets created with each
user request resulting in a new thread
that is handed over to the do get or do
post
as appropriate the init method simply
creates or
loads some data that will be used
throughout the lifecycle of a servlet
followed by the init method we have the
service method
so what is service method surface method
is the main method to perform the actual
task
the servlet container that is the web
server
calls the service method to handle
request from the client
or the browser and to write the
formatted response back to the client
each time the server receives a request
from the servlet
the server spawns a new thread and calls
service the service method checks the
http service
type and accordingly performs the crud
operations
which are the get post put
delete etc and calls do get
do post do put do delete etc methods as
appropriate
the service method is called by the
container and service method invokes
do get do post do put and do delete etc
methods as appropriate
so you have nothing to do with service
method
but you overwrite either with do get do
post
and other types depending on what type
of request you receive from the client
so this is how the init and service
methods work now digging a little deeper
we have the do get do post do delete
and do put methods so first we will
discuss about
do get method so what exactly does a do
get method do
a get request results from a normal
request from a url
or an html form that has no method
specified
and it should be hardly by do get method
followed by doget we have do post
a do post request results from a html
form that specifies
list post as the method and
it should be handled by do post method
similar to to get
and do post the do put and do delete
options are usually used to update and
delete the data
when asked by the client so to sum up
these do get do post
do put do delete we can consider them as
crud
operations so do get basically gets the
information what you're looking for
do post method usually post the
information or
provides you with the response from the
server and followed by that we have the
do put
which is usually used to update the data
which is present on your server
and finally delete which is used to
delete an existing data on your server
so these can be considered as crud
operations
and finally we arrive at the last method
which is the destroy method
the destroy method is called only once
at the end of the life cycle of a
servlet
this method gives your servlet a chance
to close database connections
halt background threats right cookie
list or hit accounts to the disk and
performs
other such cleanup activities so with
this we finish up the life cycle of a
servlet
now we shall understand its architecture
basically the architecture of a servlet
can be understood by
reverse engineering the life cycle of a
servlet so this is how the servlet
execution takes place when a client or a
browser makes a request to the web
browser
so the servlet architecture includes the
following first one
servlet interface to write a servlet we
need to implement the servlet interface
servlet interface can be implemented
directly or
indirectly by extending generic servlet
or
http servlet class followed by that
the next part is request handling
methods
as we have discussed before there are
mainly three methods defined
in servlet interface which are init
service and destroy and inside service
we have do put do post do get and do
delete methods
the first time a servlet is invoked the
init method is called
it is called only once during the life
cycle of a servlet
so we can put all your initialization
code here
the service method is used for handling
the client request
as the client request reaches the
container it creates a thread of
servlet object and request and response
object
are also created these request and
response objects
are then passed as parameter to the
service method
which then processes the client request
the service method
in turn calls the do get do post methods
if the user has extended the class from
http servlet
and lastly the creation of instances
this is based on the load of the servlet
so with this
we have finished the architecture of
servlet
moving further we shall quickly discuss
the features of servlets and then
enter into the practical mode
so the following are the features of
java servlets
the first feature is java servlets are
portable in nature
as i have mentioned above the servlets
use java as programming language
since java is a platform independent
programming language
the same holds true for servlets for
example
you can create a servlet on windows
operating system that uses glassfish as
a web server
and then later run it on any operating
system like unix
linux and apache tomcat web server
this feature makes servlet portable and
this is the main advantage of servlet
over cgi we shall discuss all the
differences of
cgi versus servlet in the next section
for now we will discuss the features
followed by the first feature
we will now enter into the second
feature which says
java servlets are efficient and scalable
once a server is deployed and loaded
onto a web server
it can instantly start fulfilling the
request of the clients
the web server invokes servlet using
lightweight thread
so multiple client requests can be
fulfilled by servlet at the same time
using the multi-threading feature of
java
compared to cgi where the server has to
initiate a new process for every client
request
the servlet is truly efficient and
scalable the next and the final feature
of java servlets is
they are robust and highly secure
by inheriting the top features of java
such as
garbage collector exception handling
java security manager
etc the servlet is less prone to memory
management issues and
memory leaks this makes the development
of web applications and servlets secure
and less error prone so these were the
important features of java servlets
now let us enter the practical mode
so we are in the practical mode right
now there were two parts in the
practical mode
the first one was to set up the
environment for java servlets
and the second one was to execute a
basic program
so this document has the following steps
to follow
that is the prerequisites before
executing a java servlet program
so we have these prerequisites where we
have to set up java home and
java path followed by that we need to
set up the home and path for jre
which is the java runtime environment
and finally catalina home and path
so catalina home and path is nothing but
the tomcat server
home and path now we will set up these
things by using the environment
variables now i'm using a windows
operating system so i'll be
using the control panel to enter the
environment variables
there you go you have edit environment
variables
so inside that just select environment
variables
and inside this you can see that i have
already set up the environment variables
for catalina home
java home and jre home so now let us
just select
java home and edit it so that we can see
how did i set it
so you can see i have named the variable
name as java home
and inside the variable value i have a
location
so this location is nothing but the java
jdk location in my local system
now followed by that we have jre home so
similar to java whom we have set up the
jre home as variable name is equals to
jre home
and the variable value is the location
of gre folder in my local system
so i have my jre folder in my local
system at c drive program files
java jre and similarly
the catalina home which is inside my
program files apache software foundation
and tomcat 8.5
so similarly we'll also check up the
path variables
so inside system variables you can see
the path
just edited so then you can see the path
variable set for
java jre and tomcat
now just select ok ok and finally
another ok
now your prerequisites have been set up
so this is how you set them
so in case if you have doubts about the
tomcat version to download
then i'll help you with that just open
google
and type in tomcat download
so now you have entered apache tomcat
official site
and since i'm using a windows operating
system i'll be selecting the 32-bit or
64-bit
windows service installer version and
after this gets
downloaded you need to set up the home
and path variables for catalina server
so once after the environment is set up
you need to follow four stages to
create a servlet program which are
creating a dynamic web project
create a servlet add servlet api jar
file and run the servlet
so to create a dynamic web project you
need to select new
and inside that you have the option of
other just select
other and inside that you'll be finding
web so select web and inside that you
need to select the dynamic web project
and select next so you just need to
name to your dynamic web project so i'll
be
naming a server then select next
and inside that you have a source folder
and now you can select
finish
now there you go java eclipse will ask
you
for opening this particular in java ee
perspective
then just select open perspective
now basically java will set up
everything you need here
and there you go you can see server
folder here which has already set up
everything you need
now what you need to do is set up a new
servlet so right click this
and select new and inside that
you can see the option of servlet just
select it
now you can see a new dialog box and
here you need to set up
the class name for now let's just type
in hello and
go to next now again next
and in here you have a lot of options
so for now we are just executing a basic
program so let's just select
do get method now let's just finish it
and there you go your servlet has been
ready so this is the basic template
created by eclipse for you
now next we need to add in the build
path so for that
you need to right click the server and
then
select build path
and here configure build path from here
you can add the external library select
the external libraries option
and you can see i have the tomcat
libraries here just select all
and open and that's how you add all the
required libraries of tomcat server
now apply and close now the last step is
to execute the project
now just to save time i have already
typed in the program
which is over here now let's try to
execute this
this program will just provide us a
simple output which is none other than
hello world now the server i have
choosed is tomcat server
let's finish it
so there you go the message has been
displayed successfully
hello welcome to simply learn now we'll
move ahead with our next topic
now that we are done with the
environment setup and the basic example
let us now discuss the advantages and
disadvantages of using
java servlets
so first we will discuss the advantages
the following are the advantages of
using servlets in java
servlet is convenient in modifying
regular html
we can write the servlet code into jsp
servlets include the feature of
multi-threading of java
we can make use of exception handling of
java
servlets have a separate layer for
business logic in the application
and finally it is easy for developers to
show and process the information
so these were the advantages of using
servlets in java
moving ahead we will discuss the
disadvantages of using
servlets so following are the
disadvantages of using servlets in java
designing a servlet is considered as a
little complicated
so let's often slow down the application
business logic of
servlet is difficult to understand we
need a jre which is the java runtime
environment
on the server to run our servlets and
finally
the data connectivity is a little
complicated
so these were the major disadvantages of
using servlets and java
moving ahead we will understand cgi
why are we learning cgi because even cgi
is similar to servlets and it also does
the web interactive job similar to
servlets
so thought you should know about some
basics of it
so let's understand its definition and
architecture
real quick so the cgi or common gateway
interface is a standard for writing
programs
that can interact through a web server
with a client
running on web browser these programs
allow a web developer to deliver dynamic
information usually in the form of an
html
via the browser a cgi program can be
written in any language
including java that can be executed by
your web server
cgi programs are commonly used to add
search engines
guest book applications database query
engines
interactive user forums and other
interactive applications
to websites in very basic terms a cgi
program must interpret
the information sent to it process the
information in the same way
and generate response that will be sent
back to the client
most of the input of cgi program is
passed into through
environment variables so with this we
will move ahead into the architecture of
common gateway interface so you can see
the architecture of
common gateway interface is completely
similar to
servlet normally the request is sent in
the form of an http request
so this particular http request is
divided amongst the cgi shells
and it will be processed by the cgi
shells based on the program provided
and the response is sent to the user now
moving ahead
we shall understand the differences
between the common gateway interfaces
and the servlet so the first difference
is
the common gateway interface scripts are
executable codes
written in native operating system while
on the other hand
the servlets are written and run using
the java virtual machine
the next difference is the common
gateway interface performance is
considered to be low
compared to servlets on the other hand
servlets are having high performance
compared to cgi's
the third difference is for a common
gateway interface
it is hard to switch between different
platforms that is the operating system
platforms
when we come into servlets the servers
are considered to be completely
platform independent followed by that
the common gateway interface scripts are
directly executed
so on the other hand servlets are
translated into
bytecode because the servlets are
executed using
the java virtual machine and in java
virtual machine
whatever the code you transfer it will
be converted into bytecode first
then executed and the last difference is
the common gateway interface is not
portable
and on the other hand we have the java
servlets to be completely portable
so these are the major differences
between the common gateway interface and
java servlets
now let us understand the java servlets
requests and responses
so first we will deal with the request
phase in request we have various types
the first one is being the http request
the http object is used to represent the
http request to a browser
that the user sends to the web
application thus anything the browser
sends is accessible
through the http request followed by the
http request
we have the request parameter the
request parameters are the parameters
that are sent from the
web browser along with the request the
request parameters are
typically sent as a part of the url or
as a part of the body of an http request
followed by the request parameter we
have the request header
the request headers are the name value
pairs sent by the browser
along with the http request the request
headers contain the information about
the web browser software being used
what type of files that the web browser
can receive etc
followed by the request header we have
the input stream
if the browser sends an http post
request request parameters and other
potential data
is sent to the server in the http
request body it doesn't have the request
parameters that is sent in http request
body
it could be pretty much as the data like
file
or soap request the next one is a
request session
the session object can hold information
about a given user
between the request so if you have set
an object into the session object during
one request
it will be available for you to read
during any subsequent request
within the same session time scope
followed by the request session
we have the servlet context the servlet
context contains the metadata related to
the application
followed by servlet context we will
enter the response phase
in the response phase we will deal with
the first one
which is the http response the http
response object is used to represent the
http response to your request
a web application sends back a response
page to the user
as a response to the http request from
the browser
sent to your web application followed by
the http response
we have the right html to initiate the
process of sending the html back to the
browser
you need to retrieve the print writer
from the http response object
this can be done using the right html
followed by the right html we have the
response header
similar to http request the http
response includes headers as well
these are responsible for all the data
written in the response
followed by response header we have
content type
the content type header is responsible
to tell the browser about the type of
content you are sending in the return
followed by content type we have the
content length the content length header
is responsible for telling you
about the number of bytes your server is
sending you in return
followed by content length we have
redirection
redirecting will help you to redirect
yourself to the different web page from
the current one
so these were the http requests and
responses in
java servlets now we will enter the next
part where we will deal with
the session tracking and cookies so
first we will understand
session tracking session simply means a
particular time of interval
session tracking is a way to maintain
state or
data belonging to a user it is also
known as
session management and servlets http
protocol is stateless
so we need to maintain state using
session tracking techniques
each time the user request to the server
the server reads the request as a new
request
so we need to maintain the state of a
user to recognize a particular user
you can understand this in a better way
by looking at the
picture shown on the presentation each
time you send a request
you will be receiving a response from
the server
as well as this particular request will
be recorded as
a state in order to recognize you as a
particular user
now after session tracking we will enter
into cookies
cookie is a small piece of information
that is persisted between
multiple client requests a cookie has a
name
a single value and optional attributes
such as comment
path and domain qualifiers a maximum age
and a version number by default each
request is considered as a new request
in cookie technique
we add a cookie with response from the
servlet so cookie is stored in
cash of a browser after that if the
request is sent
by the user the cookie is added with a
request
by default thus we recognize the user as
an old user there are two types of
copies
they are non-persistent cookie and
persistent cooking
let's understand non-persistent cookie
first
a non-persistent cookie is valid for a
single session only
it is removed each time when the user
closes the browser
now let us understand the persistent
cookie the persistent cookie is valid
for multiple sessions
it is not removed each time when the
user closes the browser
it is only removed when the user logs
out or
signs out from the browser so with this
we have come to an end of
java servlets tutorial if you have any
queries based on java servlets
then please feel free to drop them down
in the comment section below and we will
have your questions answered
from our expert team till then thank you
until next time
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd
up and get certified click here